who owns this is it America the country
that planted a flag on it or this man
who's been selling plots of it for
almost 40 years or is it us and anyone
else who bought one and has a
certificate to prove it today many
believe the moon could be the next
frontier for tourism space exploration
or even the mining of precious natural
resources which means this question
might be about to become a lot more
important in 1969 an estimated 650
million people watched as Neil Armstrong
took his first step on the surface of
the Moon
five more landings followed and then for
almost 50 years no humans went back that
is about to change there are dozens of
lunar missions planned over the next 20
years and some will carry crews the
first to land could be in 2024 when NASA
hopes to send a crew to the lunar South
Pole where it's believed water may be
frozen in craters that crew may well
include the first woman to land on the
moon after years of being left alone why
is the moon hot property once again this
book could have the answers or at least
the man who wrote it might he's Oliver
Morton senior editor at The Economist
the most simple reason perhaps is
tourism we do live in upon a planet now
with an extraordinary number of very
rich people and only some of them need
to think this is a cool idea for it to
happen
there is a Japanese billionaire who has
ordered a space flight from SpaceX Elon
Musk's company the Chinese have talked
about putting people onto the moon then
the Americans are thinking about going
back because the Chinese are thinking
back
of course none of this would be
happening if you still had to spend sort
of like a huge chunk of America's
national budget to go to the moon but in
fact you probably don't know the price
of a space launch the most expensive
part of going to the moon has dropped
substantially in 1981 NASA paid almost
62 thousand dollars a kilo to launch the
Space Shuttle last year SpaceX's Falcon
Heavy cost just under one and a half
thousand dollars a kilo that's a real
term dropped by a factor of 40 there's
another reason the moon may be an
attractive destination its resources one
of which is vital for supporting life in
space one things you don't have much
over in space near the earth is water
but in the past few decades ice has been
discovered in craters of the moon's
poles so that's something that would be
really useful if you're building a moon
base because you wouldn't have to ship
it up from Earth and there's the
potential of my noble treasure including
highly valuable platinum group minerals
leftover from asteroid impacts and the
very rare isotope helium-3 absorbed by
the moon surface from the Sun and used
in nuclear fusion to produce a clean
source of energy there are plans to mine
both but Oliver isn't convinced if the
platinum group metals are there in
really really localized rich ways there
might be something to be done there but
we don't know that that's the case the
helium-3 is there but if you're doing
something really difficult like trying
to recreate the power that drives the
Sun and a little magnetic bottle do you
really want to make life harder by
saying oh yeah and I'll use moon dust
too
it's I don't think that's a very serious
idea
as well as its resources the moon can
teach scientists more about the history
of the solar system and it could be a
proving ground for further space
exploration for example for a manned
mission to Mars but ultimately the main
driver for returning to the moon is
nationalism I think the politics of the
Moon will probably reflect the politics
of the earth now make no mistake about
it we're in a space race today
just as we were in the 1960s and the
stakes are even higher
whooshing for long patience on that she
won't come back honking laughs honking
you see a fat in the tongue tongue huh
you'll hunt golfing if two nations that
both have an interest in that trade on
the South Pole of the moon also have an
interest in say the South China Seas
then the chances that they might be
somewhat a daggers drawn on the moon is
obviously higher and this is where who
owns what on the moon really starts to
matter which brings us back to this man
he's Dennis hope in 1980 he claimed
ownership of the moon and started
selling it off for around 25 dollars an
acre
he says its netted two Millions
apparently even three former US
presidents of moon plots from him Viki
Jung is a space lawyer yes that is a
real job we showed her our lunar
certificate but you've even got land
registration for Wow and it looks very
pretty and nice but it doesn't have any
legal validity as well
this is because of an agreement signed
in 1967 called the Outer Space Treaty
meanwhile the Foreign Minister presided
at the signing of the treaty banning
nuclear weapons from outer space as well
as trying to avoid an arms race the
treaty set out certain restrictions it
states that it should be for the benefit
of all mankind and it sets out important
principles such as non appropriation so
whether you put up a flag whether you do
anything you build anything you just
don't have property rights everything
but the Outer Space Treaty only
prohibits ownership of the moon itself
the legality of who owns resources found
on the moon like metals or water is left
up to interpretation so what if say
China and America both want to mine the
same bit of the moon to work out what
could happen up here we have to look
down there so the deep sea is really not
a part of any country it's also very
hard to get to and that's like the moon
so the law of the sea is the best model
there is at the moment for what a moon
agreement might be like the law of the
sea sets out which part of the deep
ocean belongs to specific countries and
which is shared by all humankind for
those areas it has strict criteria for
how private companies can mind for their
own gain this includes respecting the
environment and ensuring some of the
proceeds go to help less developed
countries but America has refused to
ratify the law of the sea believing as
with the moon in Finders Keepers so even
if there is a new moon treaty America is
unlikely to sign up to it if it's
modeled on the law of the sea there is
definitely a need to create another
international legal framework most
countries recognize that but it is very
hard to reach consensus because a lot
have their own interests it will be a
political mess just how much of a mess
won't be known until the first crater is
mined or the first hotel is bill
and it may be many moons until the
question of who owns the moon is finally
resolved I'm Anna I'm the director of
this film if you're interested in
finding out more about plans to return
to the moon the link to our website will
take you to the economists latest
writing on this and the future of space
you can also watch our film on moon
rocks and the secrets that they revealed
and don't forget to subscribe to our
YouTube channel thanks for watching